[موسيقى]
اذا كان نزار قباني قد قال لا توجد منطقه
الوسطى ما بين الجنه والنار فانه يصح ايضا
القول لا توجد منطقه الوسطى ما بين العرين
والقن عرين الاسود وقن الدجاج ولا توجد
منطقه الوسطى ما بين من احرق روما ومن
احترق في روما ولا توجد منطقه وسطى ما بين
الناهب والمنهوب ولا توجد منطقه الوسطى
بين المستبدين والشعوب ولا توجد منطقه
وسطى بين قتيل التخمه وقتيل الجوع الى
العناوين
هل بدات نهايه ميليشيات فاجنر المرتزقه في
روسيا
قمه العقبه الامنيه هل تكون عقبه في وجه
بن جبير
البرلمان العربي يتضامن مع ضحايا الزلزال
ام مع الاسد
قيس سعيد يجدد تهديد معارضيه بالكيماوي
ويضيف عنصر الاشعه
الجابون تقرع الطناجر لرئيس فرنسا التي
تسجن سعد المجرد
رئيس وزراء مصر يدعو الى تصدير الشباب الى
الخارج
هل اباحت اسبانيا معاشره الحيوانات جنسيا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا عندما سالت كاميرا الشارع سيده
مصريه ضاقت بها الدنيا عن تمنياتها اجابت
ان تقوم القيامه
فقدت الامل بالسعاده
نفهم انتظار العداله المطلقه في الاخره
لكن بعض الاتراك لا يستطيع استعجال الاخره
بالرعب كلما شاهدوا صورا عن تبدلات في
الارض
كتلك التي انتشرت هذا الاسبوع
واثارت الدعره عما قيل انه انشقاق قطعه
ارض في احدى المناطق
وتحركها وكانها تتنفس وذلك بعد الحفره
الدائريه العميقه التي ظهرت في مدينه
قونيا ونفى الخبراء في تركيا اي ارتباط
لها بتداعيات الزلزال ما يخيف حقا اكثر من
كوارث الطبيعه هو الانسان الطبيعه لا تقتل
واحدا بالمئه مما تفعله الحروب نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القوميه الروسي ديمتري مدفي
يهدد بتوسيع الحرب خارج اوكرانيا ويحذر من
انتقال العالم الى المرحله النوويه
فالعالم الذي يخلو من روسيا لن يبقى يقول
وزير الدفاع الروسي الاكثر قربا الى بوتين
الذي يرشحه البعض لخلافته في الكرملين فهو
يده الضاربه وامين اسراره والذي يحرص
بوتين على اصطحابه معه اثناء عطلته ورحلات
الصيد الخاصه به في مختلف المناطق
هذا يصبح عند صاحب ميليشيات فاجنر يفجين
بريجوجين خائنا للوطن هو والرئيس اركان
الجيش لانهما يحاولان تدمير قواته باجنير
بائع الموت بريجوجين الذي يعرف بطباخ
بوتين ليس لجماعته صفه الرسميه غير انهم
يمتهدون القتل في سوريا وليبيا والسودان
وغيرها
يصدر رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع امرا بعد
امر يمنع تقديم الذخيره لفاجنر ومساعدتها
في النقل الجوي جاءت المعلومات للتو تفيد
بانهم رفضوا حتى امدادنا بمجارف حتى لا
يتمكن الرجال من الحفر هناك ببساطه معارضه
مباشره ومستمره وهي ليست سوى محاوله
لتدمير يمكن ان يقارن هذا بالخيانه العظمى
هل تبدا نهايه ميليشيات فاجنر المرتزقه
الرئيس بوتين الذي ينفي دائما وجود اي
علاقه له بفاجنر يشير بالقوات الخاصه
بالجيش الروسي في معارك اوكرانيا تعتبر
قوات العمليات الخاصه فخر الجيش الروسي
لقد اثبتم التفانيه والفدائيه والاخلاص في
المعركه
شركات الامن هذه لا تعكس مصالح الدوله
الروسيه فهي مجرد اعمال خاصه مرتبطه
بمصالح استخراج موارد الطاقه بكل الاحوال
يبدو ان فاجنر قد غيرت باعدادات خالد
العبود النائب السوري الذي وضع معادله
الاسد وحده مثل ما شفتي وزير الدفاع في
دمشق وماشي وجلس مع السيد الرئيس بشار
الاسد ما اجا عم يتمشى بالشام يعني ما اجى
بده يشوف الشام
بيسلم عليك كتير السلام مشتاق لك بس ما
حسن يو
واحد اثنين ثلاثه قال له اتكلوا على الله
روحوا اسرائيل لا تحتل الفلسطينيين فحسب
بل تستخدمهم ايضا في البرامج الانتخابيه
وفي اسكات المعارضين الاسرائيليين فشعار
لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت المعركه ليس امتيازا
حصريا للانظمه العربيه
انها محاوله انقلاب يريدون تحويل اسرائيل
الى ديكتاتوريه نابلس التي تعرف بدمشقى
الصغرى وعش العلماء وملكه فلسطين غير
المتوجه وجبل النار واجهت الحديد والنار
مجددا وسقط عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
فالاحتلال لم يقتل مقاومين فقط بل استهدف
مدنيين بينهم مسنون عمليه تاتي برايي
كثيرين ضمن محاوله الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تصدير ازمتها الداخليه حتى وان سرع ذلك من
الوصول الى لحظه الانفجار ردا على اقتحام
نابلس اوقفت السلطه الفلسطينيه كافه
الاتصالات مع اسرائيل لبضعه ايام فقط
فالراعي ابو مازن لا يحب القطيعه ولا
القطيع يتدرون وقد توج الاتصال الجديد
باجتماع اقليمي دولي في العقبه ظاهره
سياسي وواقعه امني وقد رفضته الفصائل
الفلسطينيه قبل ان يختتن امه امنيه
اسرائيليه فلسطينيه اللقاء الذي انعقد
بمشاركه كل من مصر والاردن والولايات
المتحده في المتجه العقبه الاردنيه المطل
على البحر الاحمر يهدف الى تقريب وجهات
النظر الامنيه بين الطرفين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلية يج
ري الحال لدفع الفلسطينيين الى الاقتتال
مع بعضهم البعض
بلا زغله وزير ما يسمى بالامن القومي
الاسرائيلي لا يعترف باجتماع العقبه
ويعتبره عقبه قد تقلل من حجم الاجتياحات
خلال شهر رمضان اما وزير الامن القومي
المتطرف في تمر بنجفير قال انما جاء في
العقبه يبقى في العقبه طبعا يعتبر ضمنا
وايضا ان على الاسرائيليين ان يكونوا
مستعدين لوقوع المزيد من القتلى في صفوفهم
في عهد وزارته ورعايته للامن القومي قتل
مستوطنان اليوم في عمليه اطلاق نار نفذها
فلسطيني في حواره بمدينه نابلس بعد ان
اعترض مركبه مستوطنيه وتعمد الاصطدام بها
ثم اطلق وابل كثيفا من الرصاص صوبها هذه
العمليه تاتي بعد اربعه ايام على ارتقاء
عشره فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر لدى اجتياح
الجيش الاحتلال البلده القديمه في نابلس
فيما ادانت السعوديه اقتحام نابلس ومجره
الاحتلال وطلبه المجتمع الدوليه بالاطلاع
بمسؤولياته لانهاء الاحتلال والعدوان ووقف
التصعيد دعت الامارات الى خفض التصعيد
وادانت الاقتحام ادانت
دوله اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه مدينه
نابلس الفلسطينيه ما اسفر عن سقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى ودعت وزاره الخارجيه
والتعاون الدولي في بيان لها السلطات
الاسرائيليه الى خفض التصعيد وعدم اتخاذ
خطوات تفاقم التوتر وعدم الاستقرار في
المنطقه وهذا خبر اخر من نفس النشره حيث
استقبل وزير الخارجيه الاماراتي الشيخ عبد
الله بن زايد مدير عام وزاره الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه رونين ليفي وبحثات تعاون في
مختلف المجالات
وزير الخارجيه والتعاون الدولي امس
مدير عام وزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه وبحث
الجانبان خلال اللقاء علاقه التعاون
الثنائي بين دوله الامارات ودوله اسرائيل
في المجالات كافه وفي المنامه استقبلت
وزيره شؤون الشباب السفيره الاسرائيليه في
البحرين لتبحث معه اوجه التعاون المشترك
في المجال الشبابي خطيب المسجد الحرام
بمكه المكرمه عبد الرحمن السديس اذان
عدوان قوات الاحتلال المتواصل على مقدسات
المسلمين وعلى مدنهم
كذا كرره المساس بمقدسات المسلمين في كنف
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وساحاته ومدنه
والاعتداء على اهله ورواده ومجاوره مفتي
عمان الشيخ احمد الخليلي دعا الى اعاده
سلطات بلاده النظر بشان سماحها للطائرات
الاسرائيليه
بالتحليق في اجوائها واعرب عن خشيته من
انتلي هذه الخطوه خطوات اخرى
[موسيقى]
التقى السيد الرئيس بشار الاسد في
اجتماعين متتاليين رؤساء البرلمانات
واعضاء الوفود البرلمانيه العربيه التي
وصلت الى سوريا رئيس الاتحاد البرلماني
العربي محمد الحلبوسي اعتبر ان الوفد جاء
الى سوريا باسم جميع اعضاء الاتحاد
ليؤكد للشعب السوري في خطوه عمليه الوقوف
والتضامن مع سوريا سيد حلبوسي اذا اردتم
ان تتضامنوا مع الشعب السوري عليكم ان
تزوروا ايضا منكوبي الزلزال ونازحي ادلب
ومخيمات اللجوء في الداخل والخارج
والمانيا وتركيا وكندا وغيرها من دول
الشتات في العالم
عليكم ان ترموا ورده على الاقل في بحار
المقابر الجماعيه التي لم تجف بعد من جثث
الهاربين انطلاقا من شواطئ تركيا ولبنان
وحتى ليبيا التي تحدث باسمها في دمشق
عقيله صالح رئيس احد البرلمانات الليبيه
كما يوصف فرد عليه رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله خالد المصري نحن في ليبيا نفخر
ونعتز بقياده فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد
وقلت له هذا اليوم انني فخور بلقائك بلقاء
الرجل رغم المؤامرات التي تهز الجبال لم
يتزحزح من مكانه نحن نعيده ونوقع ونتمنى
له السلامه بشار الاسد مجرم
جزار وهو طبعا عقيله صالح ذهب من ضمن
الانكا والاشد من ضمن وفد برلماني عربي
بالنسبه لراي وهو راي الغالب من الشعب
الليبي وراي مجلس الدوله وراي ان هذا
النظام هو نظام مجرم هو فعل ما فعل هتلر
يعني
بلسان من كان يتحدث عجيله صالح عندما قال
نحن الليبيون بلسانه هو لسان عقيل
الا يعبر عن الليبيين بوصفه
من بعد الثوره و11 سنه والشعب السوري
يعاني في الويلات فهذا يقول في كلمه خير
اعتبار دول عربيه تقاطع ايران او تجافها
ان النظام السوريه كان على حق هو تكريم
لايران بدون ما يعرفوا التي لولاها
الانهار النظام السوري فهل سيزور البرلمان
العربي قريبا طهران لتقديم الشكر الى
السيد خامنئي
نفسه الكلام بصيغه المعاكسه ينطبق على قطر
التي تقيم علاقات مستقره مع ايران فيما هي
الدوله الوحيده التي تقاطع بالكامل حليفه
ايران الاقرب في دمشق لان قطر هي الدوله
الوحيده قطر الان هي الدوله الوحيده التي
مات ذات تعارض اعاده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه ليس هناك من دوله عربيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
لا جديد في تونس الاعتقالات على حالها
وكذلك جمود الحياه الدستوريه والحركه
الانتاجيه في البلاد حتى التهديد
بالكيماوي الذي وجهه الرئيس قيس سعيد
مؤخرا الى معارضيه كرره هذا الاسبوع مع
اضافه عنصر الاشعه عليه
اشعاعات مش اشاعات
حتى
بقايا بتاع انسان لا بد من حل اما بالاشعه
ولا بالكيمياوي للقضاء على هذه الخلايا
السرطانيه الموجوده داخل المؤسسات الدوله
وفي وسائل اخرى لضرب الدوله ولضرب الوطن
وبالاسباب موجوده اسمائهم ومن يتجرا ايضا
على تبريئتهم فهو شيخ لهم غير انه لابد من
حل بالاشعه والكيمياوي للقضاء على الخياصر
سيدي الرئيس
عليش تكرهنا
علاش تكرهنا سيد الرئيس
تحسسنا كانك انت النبي صالح واحنا ثمود
وعقرنا لك الناقه نتاعك
تحسسنا احنا قريش وانت النبي محمد
اذا احنا في السير انت ما تلاقيش فينا يا
رئيس شوف شعب اخر يشبهلك الرئيسه سعيد وسع
من دائره هجومه ليشمل القاره الافريقيه
التي تسعى الى تغيير الديموغرافيا
التونسيه برايه راي اعتبر عنصريا وانتقده
الاتحاد الافريقي ولم يشد به في العالم
الى رمز التطرف العنصري زمور السياسي
الفرنسي الذي يريد طرد المسلمين والافارقه
من اوروبا تلبيه لدعوه المنظمه الحقوقيه
في تونس انطلقت اليوم مظاهره مناهضه
للعنصريه ضد المهاجرين الافارقه من جنوب
الصحراء بعد خطاب الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
الاخير والذي مدد فيه بمؤامره تستهدف
تغيير البنيه الديموغرافيه في بلاده
الاتحاد الافريقي ندد في بيان له بتص
الرئيس التونسي ووصفها بانها تثير
الكراهيه والعنصريه لكن الرئيس قيس سعيد
قدم لاحقا دليلا دامغا على عدم عنصريته
بقصه نعرض مختصرا منها
وباستطاعه ما يجد تفسيرا لها ان يتركه لنا
في التعليقات لما كنت طالبا بكليه الحقوق
وكان الاستاذ المحاضر هو الاستاذ محمد
الشرفي اقام عدد من الطلبه
بالمدرج
بالتهريج والرقص فطلب من الاعوان باخراجهم
وكان من بين هؤلاء الطلبه الذين قاموا
بالرقص والتشويش وقطع درس طالب من افريقيا
وهذا دليل على التعاون على
التونسي مع الدول الافريقيه الجنرال
الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر متخصص في اصول
الاحترام والبروتوكول فيلقي التحيه
العسكريه على شخص مدني هو رئيس نادي
مانشستر سيتي ونائب رئيس حكومه الامارات
الشيخ منصور بن زايد وبفضل اتساء المساحه
مساحه العرض يعني كانت المشاركات بعد طرد
جيشه رسميا من سلطات مالي وبوركينا فاسو
مطالبات شعبيه في الجابون بطرده شخصيا من
افريقيا
يشارك في الجابون بقمه الغابات الاستوائيه
ويزور ثلاث دول اخرى في الجوار وسيسعى
بحسب رافضين للزياره الى ضمان مصالح
الشركات الفرنسيه الملوثه للبيئه في
افريقيا التي سبقته اليها بكل الاحوال
روسيا والصين
[موسيقى]
الفنان المغربي سعد المجرد سجينا في فرنسا
وللسنوات السته القادمه مدنا باغتصاب شابه
وبضربها في احد فنادق باريس قبل اكثر من
ست سنوات
نستمع ثم نقارن ما بين تعامل باريس مع سعد
المجرد ومع رفعت الاسد الحكم الصادر بحق
لمجرد يقضي بسجنه فورا لمده 6 سنوات على
خلفيه اغتصاب فتاه الماريوت باريس في
اكتوبر 2016 سعد المجرد في 37 من العمر
اودع فورا في السجن وامامه عشره ايام
لاستئناف الحكم طبعا العقوبه واجبه في
فرنسا على كل مذنب الا على رفعه الاسد عمي
الرئيس السوري الذي حكمه القضاء الفرنسي
بالسجن لمده اربع سنوات ثم هربته
المخابرات الفرنسيه الى سوريا بحسب صحيفه
الفرنسيه ذائعه الصيت تقديرا لتعامله معها
على مدى عقود ولا سيما ضد مجموعات
فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
اول شيء من صدره احنا خدماته سياحه وبشر
على حالنا يعني ما نجي نقول بدنا نصدر
خيار وبندوره ما حنصدر خيار وبندوره كل
مهندس من صدره بيبعت لاهله قد موسم
البندوره عندما اقترح النائب اللبناني
طوني فرنجيه مؤخرا تصدير الشباب والكفاءات
الى الخارج ليرسلوا الدولارات الى
عائلاتهم في لبنان سخر منه كثيرون ولبنان
فيه خمس سته ملايين لبناني على اكبر تقدير
في مصر رئيس الوزراء مصطفى مدبولي يتبنى
نفس الطرح نصدر الايادي البيضاء لتاتينا
بالعمله الخضراء فهل تتحول حكوماتنا الى
مكاتب سفريات ان هيبقى جزء من مستهدفات
هذه الاستراتيجيه اننا اشجع على زياده
العماله المصريه اللي بتخرج الى الدول
الاخرى لان ده جزء من زياده الصادرات ولكن
بطريقه غير مباشره العامل المصري او الشاب
المصري لما بيسافر وبيشتغل بره طبعا
تحويلات المصريين في الخارج انتم عارفينها
بتمثل واحده من اهم موارد الدوله في
العمله الاجنبيه في المتفرقات العربيه
ايضا اعلامي عراقي يدخل سجنا لمروجي
المخدرات ويصوروا معهم فيلما غريبا يقول
انه يهدف الى تحذير كل من ظلم العراقيين
كلهم من الداخل والخارج من فوق لتحت
امبسهالكين مقطوع بالحبس
اشتروه
ولكم والله هذا العراقي يشور
كم العراقيين يتشوروا وشوفوا هاي رساله
خل كلكم انتم تسمعون الفاسدين كل انسان
تجاوز على حقوق العراقيين راح يكون هذا
مصيره وراح يبكي هذا
[موسيقى]
هل اباحت اسبانيا معاشره الحيوانات
الجنسيا الخبر نشرته بالعربيه شبكه روسيا
اليوم
وتناقلته مواقع ووكالات اخباريه عربيه
واجنبيه ويقول ان اسبانيا اجازت ممارسه
الجنس مع الحيوانات طالما لا تؤذيها لكن
الخبر غير صحيح بحسب منصه تاكد التي اكدت
بطلانه وان الصحافه الاسبانيه وصفته بانه
خبر مزيف بكل الاحوال وبالتسلسل المنطقي
سيصل الغرب الى اجازه المعاشره الزوجيه
للحيوانات ان لم يكن اليوم فغدا وغدا
سيعتبرون من يرفض هذا التوجه متخلفا قامعا
للحريه
الناشطه اللبنانيه ديما صادق لطالما تعرضت
للتنمر والتهديد وقد تضمننا معها سابقا
الان نتضامن ضدها مع المتضررين من تنمرها
وتجهيلها وربما تحقيرها افكار جماعه من
الناس يناهز عددهم ملياريين نسمه المسلمين
فهي تقول انها ليس عندها مقدسات وهذا
شانها الذي يكفله القانون وحتى الاسلام
الذي خير الناس في سوره الكهف
اما ان تقول ان الحجاب قيد فرضه المجتمع
تاريخيا لتقييد المراه فهذا يجرح مشاعر
المسلمات لانه اولا حكيم الصادق وثانيا
يخالف اصول التعايش مع المسلمين اقله في
لبنان والدول العربيه
ثالثا من فرض الحجاب هو الله ورسوله
بايمان المسلمين وليس جماعه من الذكوريين
انا ما عندي مقدسات انا بحترم انه انت بدك
تحطي الحجاب انا ما حاجي انعك واشارعك ما
تحطيه بس سوري انا كمان الي كامل الحريه
اني اعبر عن رايي انا رايي اعتبر انه
الحجاب هو نوع من القيد اللي فرضوا
المجتمع تاريخيا على المراه ليكبرها فهيدا
بيحق لي اني اقوله اذا كان الحجاب يقيد
المراه كما تقول قد ياتي بهيج ويقول ان كل
اللباس من فوق لتحت ومن جوا لبرا يقيد
ويجعلها خائفه من جسد تريد ان تخفي ليش
الحل عند بهيج وربما عن غيره كمان هو
السمو فوق ثقافه الاقمشه والاربطه هذا
الكلام هو الان واقعي فحاله التعري الكامل
مسموح بها في الغرب في بعض المدن او على
بعض الشواطئ فهل سياتي من يقول لنا غدا ان
رفض التعري الكامل هو موروث قمعي ذكوري
[موسيقى]
ختاما حين علم جورج برنارد شو ان معجبين
باعماله الادبيه يجمعون تبرعات لاقامه
تمثال له في لندن قال لهم اعطوني المبلغ
وانا ساقف بنفس بدلا من التمثال وفي اي
مكان تختارونه
برناردو كان احد مفكرين الاشتراكيه
السلميه فانتقد ذات يوم النفاق الغرب وقال
ان تمثال الحريه موجود في الولايات
المتحده تحديدا دون اي مكان اخر في العالم
لان الناس عاده لا يقيمون التماثيل الا
للموتى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الحياه